hi
today i want to talk about learning a
language from scratch
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
you can click on the bell for
notifications
and i am going to talk today about how i
use link to start a language from
scratch
now
i have this is kind of the fourth in
this series of videos on
studying effectively
and one of the themes that you will have
you know heard throughout each of these
videos is the importance of listening
and reading so then people say well how
can i listen and read
uh
with a language that i know nothing
about like from scratch how do you start
listening and reading
so i thought it would be useful to go on
to go over some of the basic principles
what i do when i'm starting from scratch
because very recently i have started
from scratch
in persian in arabic in turkish in greek
uh you know i can't remember all the
languages that i've started from scratch
and the way i start from scratch
is that i use the mini stories and i use
the many stories because there is so
much repetition in each story so you
have 60 stories where within each story
there is lots of repetition the same
vocabulary repeats five times within the
story
one of the problems with more
conventional
learner books starter books
is that while it may it pretends to be
easier in fact
not
a lot of the vocabulary repeats within
the lesson or even later on in the book
and we do need vocabulary to repeat if
we're going to have a chance to remember
it
also
i will demonstrate
i'll show you myself learning indonesian
from scratch now i i had some brief
exposure to indonesian because my wife
and i uh in 1975 we were in bali
so i remember a few words like
um
how much or three makassi
uh thank you thank you
and i remember being in an airplane and
i heard antoine prempuan which is ladies
and gentlemen but that's about it
uh so i will demonstrate how i start
from scratch
uh
with the many stories
and one of the things that i'll point
out in the many stories is
while most people go from lesson one to
lesson two to lesson three
the language is the language the
language isn't so much less than one
lesson two lesson three it's not obvious
that lesson five is more difficult than
lesson one the very high frequency words
will appear in lesson one and lesson two
and lesson three and lesson four and
lesson five and ten and twenty and
thirty so
uh with that i'd like you to have a look
at me sort of dealing with indonesian in
link we are uh
i'm in persian right now
doing this very interesting podcast in
persian
but i want to
sort of experience going to a language
for the first time so we're going to
change the language
and we're going to go to something that
i haven't done
practically haven't done anything on
indonesian okay i've got two
words in indonesia and i think i spent
some time just looking at it just
exploring it to see what's there
so in the library
i mean let's see my lessons
i guess i i looked at the many stories
and i looked at this other thing i was
curious buddha but let's go to the mini
stories because
starting a language from scratch
uh that's what i would do so if we look
at our statistic 97 of the words in here
are
new to me the reason is 97 because i
remember i did look at a lesson
and looked up a few words
uh here in story one so if we look up
story one and i want to point out
something that i think is quite
important
and which i mentioned earlier is when
you're starting in a language you don't
have to start at one you don't want to
start necessarily how are you
father mother sister brother
[Music]
the present tense isn't necessarily
easier than the past tense there is no
real order
so
i think we're conditioned to want to go
story 1 story 2 is 33
but it doesn't really matter
um
if i look at story one here
you will see that i did spend some time
i don't know when
looking at this and looked at these
words i don't remember any of these
words i did this just as an experiment
some time ago
but what i'm going to do instead
is i'm going to go to the next lesson
and let's assume that we start on lesson
two
some of the words that showed up in
lesson one will be here in lesson two
and so the whole thing about starting
from scratch is you just want to
discover the language i could look up a
grammar book and get some
hints as to how the language works uh
verb
you know
subject
subject verb noun or whatever but it
doesn't matter we're just going to
explore so this first word
means following next okay
ini
adela
so
the following is a story
now this is a capital so i'm assuming
it's a person's name
and okay liburan
so i'm just going to discover the
language so the following is a story
about poojie
and
libero and her holiday in her winter
holidays okay now i have an advantage in
doing the many stories in that i've done
them in so many different languages okay
okay she's obviously excited
so
by looking these words up i can actually
follow the meaning here
so
what i would normally do
and i should point out too that in terms
of dictionaries
i'm using babla
i could look up you know again it
depends what what your native language
is you can choose from a variety of
dictionaries some languages will have
more than others
what does this
say so
this looks to be
a dictionary entirely in indonesian
may not be so meaningful for me i don't
think i'll use it again
maybe at a later stage
so i close this
so i'm going to stay
with
let's see what did babala give me
here so this gives me more information
i'm going to stay with babala
and google translate okay i can do one
more sentence now of course i can listen
to this in fact what i would normally do
i should point out
is that i would go and do this in
sentence mode
that way
i can look at it sentence by sentence
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so here
i take this sentence
i might spend some time there or i go to
the next sentence
ah it says i met my
daily target you can set your own target
i don't worry about those things but
some people like it it must should
vacation
okay so
i mean
i'm going through these these words will
all be
status one
and i i won't go through the whole thing
i mean i can do the next sentence whoops
that wasn't what i wanted to do
uh where are we here
yeah okay so here again
satan
so
i would normally and and i think that's
enough here of of going through the many
stories
here uh and and let me explain a little
bit how i would use these many stories
and how it eventually enables me to
break into the language
all right so
it gives you a bit of a sense that that
i begin my contact with a new language
by just discovering what's there
some languages have the verb at the end
some languages have the verb in the
middle
and some books will tell you this but
actually as you go through discovering
the language translating each word if
necessary translating a phrase you start
to discover the language so
if typically what i would do is i would
pick my way through one story
then i would listen to it
i can listen to it and by the way i
would do the story in sentence mode
definitely it's much easier to do in
sentence mode and then you can listen to
each sentence
and after having worked your way through
and looked up words
and what i didn't show in the
demonstration was
using the flash cards typically i would
whenever i turn the page i would do some
flash guarding while those uh words are
still fresh in my mind
and having done all of that if i then go
away and listen to the story i won't
understand much okay
that's the reality and so then i have to
go back and i'll read it again
and pretty and and after reading it
again and looking up words again and
going through flashcards again
uh
then i go and listen to it and i still
don't understand much
and but then i will move on
to the next lesson and i typically will
go in sequence but you don't have to
uh but it's better to go on sequence
because then you remember what you've
done
and so normally i would start with
lesson one and then lesson two and
lesson three and so forth
and i'll understand twenty percent
eventually you know i'll start to
understand ten twenty thirty percent i
keep on doing this but i also and and in
fact it's been proven based on you know
research and in
cognitive processes in our brain
don't spend your whole time trying to
nail down lesson one
uh the efficiency declines very quickly
rather you should move on to the next
lesson because even another lesson that
you don't understand is still a new
lesson the brain likes novelty so i
typically will spend a fair amount of
time on lesson one understand after a
while understand i understand more and
more when reading it with the help of a
dictionary
uh listening without the reading i
understand very little
but then i'll keep on moving forward
lesson two lesson three lesson four
lesson five then i'll go back to lesson
one
and by the time you reach lesson 10
lesson one which you've now listened to
15 times it's starting to make sense and
that's basically the process combination
of listening
while reading in sentence mode
looking up words looking at words again
and again
reviewing words in flashcards after each
page
and then of course a lot of listening
away from it not understanding an awful
lot but now you're more and more curious
like what is that meaning that i can't
seem to remember and you go back
and all of a sudden as was the case for
me with say persian and arabic which
have a much more difficult script i mean
indonesian
has the advantage that it's written in
the latin alphabet but i did this for
persian and arabic now i will also get
myself a book teach yourself or
you know colloquial because it's it's
nice to cover the same material in
different ways so i'll read through it
and they'll have some different
monologues or dialogues per each lesson
and they'll explain some things about
the language which might be useful to me
i won't fully be able to use those
explanations but it all it's all part of
my
gradually discovering the language i
should say that indonesian would be an
attractive one to do i'm not about to
abandon persian and arabic but indonesia
is spoken by
i think if we add in malaysia and
indonesia 200 million people
uh i think there are common words with
with tagalog i'm not sure
it's an important part of the world it's
an important language
it's meant to be easy
i don't know if that's true or not
but
certainly the writing system is easy for
us
there are no tones to deal with
so it's one that i may very well
go and learn later on but i i i think
it's a it's an easy one to use as a
demonstration of how to start a language
uh from scratch and i can assure you i
use the same process in much more
difficult languages like persian and
arabic
the important thing is not to get
worried about you don't understand
trust the fact that the brain will
eventually start to form some patterns
will eventually start to
understand it it seems at first
impossible and it seemed as particularly
for me
with persian with the arabic script you
know impossible
but you just have to stay with it you
just have to stay with it and keep
listening and i end up listening to
these stories 30 40 50 times but not all
at once not listening to it over and
over again trying to force myself to
understand it i go through it and and
and continue and then go back and and
sometimes i listen to the
you know you there is a function that
linked listen to the course audio so
that'll be set up on my iphone i can
listen to it i can shuffle it and slowly
slowly slowly all of this starts to make
sense once you have a base as in say the
many stories
you can then branch off into more
difficult um you know authentic content
that you might want to import from
somewhere or you can find in our library
but i think the many stories because
there's so much repetition and and
remember you don't need to ace the most
frequent 500 words they're going to show
up anyway
they will show up don't worry about it
you have to recognize that there's going
to be a long period where you have to
acquire these you know relatively less
frequent words
uh
and which are very important to the
meaning of any context
uh however the the the many stories is
the place where i get a start in the
language i get a sense of the language
i get some basic vocabulary some basic
phrasing
now i'm ready to start exploring beyond
that but that's how the sort of
listening and reading starting from
scratch when you know nothing about the
language that's how i do it so i hope
that was uh helpful
and i i'm going to offer you a couple of
videos that kind of follow along in the
same
vein